[Music]
there are more African Americans with
coronavirus disease people who's gonna
let us disembark what is Jacqueline here
everyone I'm Jennifer in New York and
I'm Kurumi in Tokyo it's May 8th 2020
and here's quick tapes wrap of the
pandemic this week Philadelphia was one
of the many cities that saw Cova 19
disproportionately affecting the black
community that data led a group of
medical professionals straight into the
underserved areas to help I'm seeing
everything whole families of people
where mom grandma kids
everyone's positive police officers
coming needing to get tested that can't
get tests at work there's a huge need
for us here we are at one of the harder
hit ZIP codes in Philadelphia where
there are more African Americans with
coronavirus disease and think about how
to use your skills and your talents to
impact this community and that's what we
did once we decided we were gonna do it
it took 48 hours to get out on the
street in testing
the surgeon and director I would love
them all to watch my technique so who
wants to go first it was reported that
more african-americans were dying than
other groups in the city but the tests
are not in our community and they're not
easily accessible there were so many
barriers and in seeing that there was no
way to really reduce the incidence of
disease and death without testing people
and once I saw the city was not doing
that broadly that's how this consortium
came to to be so then I just started
going down the list okay I have some
testing kits in my office my colleagues
have testing kits so I drove around the
neighborhood and picked them up and then
we had a zoom call with 30 healthcare
professionals just to say who's
available who's comfortable testing
who's not comfortable testing I reach
back out to the city and I said I need
the zip codes where the majority of
people are being diagnosed and dying and
then I reached out to my pastor and said
could you identify a church in each one
of these zip codes where we could use
the parking lot we went from doing 10 to
20 tests a day to 350 almost 400 today
we'll probably do 250 to 300 but that's
only because we don't have any more
testing
after folks are tested they can be
treated they can be isolated they can
reach out to all the people they've been
in contact with and quarantine we don't
want this to just be a band-aid we want
to help them establish care with some
providers that will care about and be
empathetic to their cause the whole
health disparity a portion of it is who
is providing your care is it someone who
is empathetic to you it is someone who
knows your struggle and oftentimes it is
people of color doctors of color taking
care of people of color the only
limiting factor we have is supplies and
it's great that the students are
volunteering but eventually they're
gonna have to get back to their work so
financial support from the city from the
state from the federal government would
go a long way but I don't have any of
that now there needs to be an office
whose responsibility is not just when
there's a crisis but every day to handle
something like this
this is a captain of the bridge 41
people had been tested positive for
Corona buyers it's never gonna happen to
me it couldn't happen to me you'll just
feel desperate when you're at sea who's
gonna let us disembark hundreds of
passengers on these ships have been
infected and bloomberg businessweek has
been reporting in depth on what went
wrong and what's next for Carnival
navigating this very challenging crisis
[Music]
all right Joe so today we wanted to talk
to you about the global race to find a
corona virus vaccine we know that
there's over 100 vaccines being tested
but can you tell us some of the leading
projects right now there are over a
hundred different vaccine projects that
are in some phase of exploration that
can mean anything from having a possible
method to develop a vaccine all the way
up through human trials there's only a
handful of these vaccines that actually
are in human trials right now right now
everything's at a very early stage when
you do vaccine development you're giving
it to healthy people and so your
tolerance for what is gonna be safe
versus what it's gonna be
effectiveness really tilts towards the
safe side some of the goals right now
are seeing how much of that that you can
compress can you compress some of the
human testing instead of having each
company run its own set of trials would
you try to create one giant master trial
with a single placebo group and see how
each vaccine does against that the
entire effort right now to try and see
where can you try to do steps at the
same time while still trying to produce
the quality of evidence that you need to
know if it is safe and effective and
doesn't that present its own concerns
though like expediting this whole
process that typically takes months into
what you're saying is a few months
typically five years would be a really
really fast timeline for developing a
vaccine the Ebola vaccine that we have
they started work on that in 2014 and we
only got that at the very end of last
year and when you push anything in the
drug or vaccine world of course there
are risks there are financial risks that
you're gonna do something and spend a
whole bunch of money on it it's not
gonna work and it's gonna be a big waste
there are safety risks where if
you haven't studied the vaccine
effectively and you don't know how it
acts and there are scientific risk this
stuff is really hard to do and it's no
guarantee whatsoever that it'll work in
the end I think there's a tremendous
amount of risk in these accelerated
strategies just as there's always a
tremendous amount of risk in drug
development and vaccine development in
general do they know whether this
particular coronavirus strain mutate if
and when we do get a vaccine if people
will need to take regular vaccinations
all viruses mutate the question is does
the mutation actually matter does it
change how the virus behaves does it
change how it infects people does it
change how sick people get when they are
infected
does it affect a part of the virus that
a vaccine is targeting those are big
questions but I think they're ones that
haven't been answered and we don't
really see a lot of evidence yet in one
direction or another what the effect of
any mutation is going to be what's the
likelihood that a vaccine won't be
developed and what sort of challenges
would that present I think that's a
situation that we have to prepare for we
have as a society a pretty good track
record in terms of developing vaccines
but we don't have a great track record
of developing vaccines on the timeline
that we're trying to with this pandemic
I think we have to be prepared for a
world in which we don't necessarily have
a vaccine at the same time we may have
effective drugs against this that do
reduce the risk for people who do get
sick a vaccine is a extremely important
answer but it's not the only answer to
this medical problem why is the vaccine
so important to develop right now and
eventually for people to take well a
vaccine is what creates the type of
immunity that you want to have a way
that helps either wipe the disease out
or push it out of the human population
when you have broad spread immunity you
don't have to worry about things like
needing a drug the vaccine if it's
effective can create a level of group
immunity that can be the most powerful
weapon that we have against an infection
like this
[Music]
[Music]
she's a cross between Martha Stewart and
Kim Kardashian we talked to China's
live-streaming Queen about how she's
helping struggling businesses out in her
own way for those who don't know where
she's a cross between Martha Stewart and
Kim Kardashian we're here today at the
front of the dome from oil factory where
Waya
who hosts an hours-long fundraiser for
Han struggling businesses back on April
1st
she actually sold a rocket for 40
million yen which is roughly about six
million dollars 40 million people in
China are watching his life's in the
show
I see herself and tasty breathing from
duck neck to crayfish life is slowly
returning back to normal behind right
across the street from the four
non-secret walkers we were told by the
police not to take any photos in front
of the market we heard today that allow
the sellers will be
to the outskirts of she appeared to
raised 226 million people might see my
job now accordion teens are fever
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
South Africa has had one of the
strictest lock downs in the world the
government said a ban on the sale of
alcohol and tobacco would expire once
the lockdown ended but now seems to have
gone back on some of those promises this
is seventh Avenue in Mobile Johannesburg
usually one of the city's most popular
places to come socialize dance drink and
smoke but for well over a month not a
single barrel pack of cigarettes has
been sold here legally anyway
long time between drink the prohibition
on alcohol and cigarettes here is part
of a raft of restrictions on consumers
into curbing the spread of coronavirus
south african government in justifying
its decision frame drinking as an
impediment to social distancing and also
pointed to its links to risky behavior
domestic abuse accidents and violent but
a high incidence of various diseases
nationwide it raised the alarm that
millions could be more susceptible to
catching the disease if drinking and
smoking continue unabated
but above all government said it needs
to free hospital beds and trauma related
to alcohol is known to fill up emergency
rooms we've certainly shown through our
modeling that we probably say they just
had a five thousand trauma peds per week
through the banning of liquor sales in
South Africa
how many people per day can we fairly
confidently say we're saving because of
the locked on measures of alcohol
it's about 15 deaths per day but if you
if you multiply that by the number of
days the lockdown over 35 days the
mid-level figure would be 515 lives
saved which is substantially probably
double what we're seeing in terms of
lives lost so far from Kerr the 19th but
this is little consolation to people who
rely on alcohol and tobacco sales to
earn a living there's a real problem for
the
surviving through the alcohol to selling
alcohol as a pity for them but at the
same time alcohol
[Music]
people are drinking a lot so if you guys
are open the alcohol packs a lot of
families I root for food and stuff like
them thank you for all that you've done
other critics meanwhile say government
has overstepped with punitive rules that
impede individual freedom of choice
people might think I support prohibition
I think we call the prohibitionist on
Twitter but I'm not I consume alcohol
and I don't like people telling me what
to do but many people are living in very
crowded difficult circumstances and
government can't have different policies
for different socio-economic groups we
have to look at the way drinking occurs
more wealthy people drink generally than
poorer but the burden is higher amongst
the poorest exits of society when you're
limiting people's liberties I think
governments do better when they take the
population with them I think it's very
important to share signs of information
we we need to do more of that with with
alcohol particularly and also with
tobacco it we haven't done that manage
that PR process Locke certainly I think
we all thought that these cigarette ban
was going to be lifted and we really
just had the population told to go cold
turkey without much support and I think
a caring government it would be good to
see showing some empathy for for people
who struggling with this rather than
having the image being a law enforcement
image if we catch you we going to lock
you up you don't need it the legal sale
of cigarettes unlimited sale of alcohol
is only expected when a more relaxed
phase of lockdown is implemented and
when that happens is still anyone's
guess
[Music]
trolls them maybe breaking into your
online group chats so here are some of
our tips to protect you against the zoom
bombing what is she doing here
what am I doing here indeed ah the zoom
meeting but now ubiquitous online
platform that many of us are using for
everything from work calls to distance
learning to virtual happy hours but with
that has also brought the so called zoom
bombing
that's when uninvited guests popped into
our meetings often with less than pure
or even hateful messages in response the
nation's largest school system the New
York City Department of Education banned
zoom from online classrooms citing
security and privacy concerns several
states attorneys general have begun
looking into the platform and the FBI
has even issued warnings
zooom CEO recently addressed the
security issues saying your commitment
to security practices and privacy
practices in this process I know while
committing to this in the future as well
but there are some simple actions you
can take now to help protect yourself
against would be zoom bombers first
don't share your meeting link on social
media even if that seems like an easy
way to get everyone together that makes
it public and anyone can join with that
information second and this may seem
obvious but use a password and lock your
meeting once everyone's there also
consider random meeting identifiers
instead of your personal meeting ID
hosting and finally if anyone you don't
want their does get in you can always
kick them out
[Music]
[Music]
hi everyone I'm Sara Pontic and I am a
markets reporter with Bloomberg News by
this point in time it is abundantly
clear that the labor market has been hit
hard and fast as the coronavirus force
entire economies to shudder from cities
to states to entire countries jobs were
lost here's one statistic to really
consider in the decade-long economic
expansion that began in 2009 after the
financial crisis just about 21 and a
half million jobs are created in the
United States well in the six weeks
ended at the end of April about 30
million people filed for unemployment
insurance effectively meaning that over
a decade's worth of job gains were wiped
out now of course the hope is that these
losses will be temporary these
horrifying numbers will be temporary and
as economy starts to reopen businesses
will hire workers back now as some
states are starting to come back online
they are opening slowly through phases
we will get a sense of this how quickly
are these businesses actually bringing
employees and workers back online
however the impact across states across
industries has not been equal for
example when it comes to states those
are the highest insured unemployment
rate there the likes of Vermont Michigan
Connecticut and Pennsylvania that as of
the end of April at the same time when
it comes to industries you can imagine
those in the Travel and Leisure space
have been hit hardest hotels restaurants
airlines we've heard this time and again
but we continue to hear from more
individual companies about what their
actual plans are for example this past
week alone we heard from the likes of
Airbnb they said that they are letting
go of a quarter of their staff United
Airlines said that they're gonna let go
of 30% of their managerial and
administrative staff when government
restrictions lift a little bit later on
this year we also learned that Windham
hotels had laid staff off at the same
time NBC Universal is also weighing
layoffs however there is a bright side
and you can say some companies at least
are
hiring workers to keep up with demand
for example Amazon has hired about
175,000 workers war has hired a hundred
fifty thousand workers and they also
announced plans to hire fifty thousand
more companies like CVS also Kroger and
Papa John's they have also been hiring
and Shake Shack just recently announced
that they are bringing on some workers
that were previously furloughed so as we
do see states start to come back online
we'll see if others follow suit
[Music]
[Music]
this is a captain of the bridge 41
people have been tested positive for
coronavirus it's never gonna happen to
me it couldn't happen to me that's what
me and my friends were saying on the
ship oh yes please stay inside you
staterooms and to not go outside all the
staterooms
you just feel desperate when you're at
sea who's gonna let us disembark
I don't think that they were terribly
transparent about what they knew when
they knew it
Carnival is of course the biggest cruise
ship company in the world and since this
began their ships more than any other
companies have been struck by these
outbreaks of kovat onboard hundreds of
passengers on these ships have been
infected and some have even died and
bloomberg businessweek has been
reporting in deaths on what went wrong
and what's next for Carnival navigating
this very challenging crisis
[Music]
On February 3rd the diamond princess was
around the coast of Japan it had made
stops in Hong Kong it had gone to Taiwan
and elsewhere was supposed to be our
last night on the cruise we were
supposed to get off the next morning
around 6:30 that night an announcement
comes throughout the entire ship tested
positive for coronavirus that's really
when we knew that we probably were not
getting off the ship that next morning
so the ship cruises toward Japan and
finally anchors in the evening of
February 3rd at that point carnival says
the Japanese health officials came
aboard and started doing temperature
checks health screenings unfortunately
according to passengers this wasn't a
really serious quarantine a passenger
said that they were free to go about the
ship my cabin mate and the other two
guys that we were traveling with who
were in the cabin next door they they
went out and they had a grand old time
that day you know as most people did
eating in the restaurants watching the
live house bands eventually they find
out that there is actually cause for
concern
[Music]
tested positive for echovirus we have
confirmed 10 positive cases and based on
this we are going to quarantine the
entire ship for a minimum of 14 days so
that that's when it officially began we
are currently in the middle of day 2 of
the quarantine
it is currently day 3 apparently 41 new
cases on the ship there are 38 new
people who have tested positive 44 new
cases 66 we continue to see the numbers
go up every single day it was an
emotional roller coaster in the end more
than 700 people were infected and
tragically at least 11 people ended up
dying and this was just the beginning of
the crisis for this company
I want to highlight one of the most
impressive turnaround stories of our era
if not the most impressive turnaround
I've talked about carnival CCL the
world's largest cruise line are you
bigger than the US Navy you know that's
a good question I have a compared number
of ships but I doubt it the cruise
industry is is really massive Carnival
Cruise they say they see about 13
million people annually this is a
booming market that people love to
cruise we've probably done two dozen
cruises some times we've done 2 or 3 in
a year we're lucky cruises are the
perfect combination between being
convenient being affordable and allowing
you to just relax and you pack wants to
unpack once your hotel moves with you
your restaurant moves with you
Carnival is specifically they own about
30 to 50 percent of the market their
annual revenue amounts to about 20
billion dollars more recently Carnival
has run into some troubles you might
have seen them in the news in the 2010s
they had a boat that capsized and
actually sunk and killing about 30
people and then later on they had a very
high-profile incident in which they lost
power on the ship and none of the
plumbing worked but under Arnold Donald
who was the current CEO of Carnival
they've undergone and a remarkable
turnaround since about 2013 the more we
give people the opportunity to connect
and experience the world together the
more spectacular our world will be you
saw the market cap in the first five
years under his tenure essentially
doubled to about 50 billion dollars
ironically leading into this whole
crisis that we've seen you had Arnold
Donald promising that he was actually
going to correct things he had a plan in
place to fix all these shortcuts that
Carnival had historically been taking
our task our mission double-digit return
invested capital next year for you well
I want to congratulate you on the
turn the whole trend has been up after
the diamond princess ship about a month
passes and then another ship the grand
princess they deal with essentially the
same crisis we boarded the ship in in
San Francisco and we we did think there
would be a little more enhanced
screening because of what had happened
on the diamond princess at a minimum we
thought they would have at least taken
our temperature as we boarded this ship
but that never happened and things just
kind of exploded on our way home the
first tester ring and the coronavirus is
on board the Grand Princess the Coast
Guard delivered tests in dramatic
fashion and 21 people tested positive
for the virus it just kind of escalated
quickly quickly they you know
sequestered us to our rooms and
delivered food to us in our rooms and
obviously that was a nature shock of
something's wrong so like the diamond
princess in Japan which they sailed
immediately back to port the Grand
Prince is headed back to their homeport
of San Francisco thirty-five hundred
people stuck on that cruise ship off the
coast of California they will finally be
coming ashore all passengers and crew
will be tested for the corona virus
those that need to be quarantined will
be quarantined
in the end it proved a much smaller
outbreak than the diamond princess but
that's most likely because not everyone
chose to get tested in the end more than
130 people tested positive and at least
five passed away
as these issues are happening aboard the
Grand Princess another ship owned by a
different Carnival Cruise Line which is
holland America's and AM is sailing
around the cruise basically set sail
more or less the same day that the US
State Department warned people not to be
going on cruises and the company just
forged ahead with the cruise for some
reason they decided to keep going life
was good that first week everything was
great but I saw a friend's picture about
having issues getting toilet paper and
other things I was kind of concerned as
to how this was gonna play out
March 14th the ship received word that
Chile was planning to close its ports to
any cruise ship and from then on out
that ship was at sea with nowhere to
port on March 22nd the captain came on
the announcement and said we have people
sick with a flu-like illness everybody's
got to be confined to their quarters the
whole ship's going into quarantine March
22nd was kind of a I guess a different
feel it didn't feel like a cruise
anymore
sometimes I sat out on a deck at night
and I would just listen to the waves now
sadly sometimes I listened also to a
cascade of people coughing
after everybody was confined to quarters
for a few days the captain came on the
announcements said you know we're sorry
to report that four people have passed
away over the last couple of days so
many crew on this and AM we're getting
sick that they were having trouble
taking care of all the passengers and so
the company made the decision to bring
in another ship called the Rotterdam
they started ferrying passengers five
six seven hundred passengers who seemed
to be less sick they put them on the
Rotterdam so now they had two ships full
of passengers that could not come to
Port Panama didn't even want them to go
through the canal finally the Panamanian
government decided after all to let them
go through the canal and that's what
happened both those ships pass through
the canal and they slowly made their way
back to Florida after days at sea and
with their fate up in the air a pair of
Holland America cruise ships were given
clearance to dock at Port Everglades
Thursday afternoon yay we're back home
back through the states there were quite
a number of people that were actually
sick and they were taken to hospitals
and of course there were those four
people who had passed away that had to
be taken home or find a way home we've
gone through Ebola zika MERS SARS the
industry because we're global we have to
deal with this stuff you know it's been
devastating temporarily but the
long-term future will be great as long
as we all stand together so since this
crisis began
carnival its business has really been
suffering we've seen its stock really
plummet quite significantly we spent
weeks talking to company executives and
the company was really upbeat and
positive if not defiant the CEO Arnold
Donald kept saying look back when this
first affected our first ship the world
still hadn't known about coronavirus yet
it was still in his words it was still a
China issue
we talked to the CDC we talked to the
head of their cruciate task force dr.
Cindy Freedman and she said that excuse
does not fly it would be one thing if it
was only aboard the diamond princess or
even the Grand Princess those first two
ships but the fact that this crisis
continued to affect Carnival afterward
essentially Carnival should have known
better I look forward to cruising again
one day but you know I realize the
paradigm has changed it's very easy to
say would you ever cruise again but I'm
wondering well what's the world gonna
look like where we ever be going to a
concert a sporting event
yeah it's not just cruise one thing that
I do agree with Arnold Donald on he said
this is an unprecedented generational
global event and I think that's totally
spot-on and in the years ahead we're
gonna look back and we're gonna see who
responded to that generational crisis
well and who did not
you'll have made it through the time to
great sacrifice and great need and no
one will be more fresh to the task of
restarting our measure of normalcy than
you you chosen ones alright that wraps
things up first this week but remember
you can get all of your coronavirus news
from quick-take 24/7 on twitter
instagram facebook and youtube and for a
daily recap of the day's top stories
subscribe to our newsletter thanks for
watching we'll see you next week
[Music]